вже 45 року в легендарне місто машина
часу радуючи своїх шину вільники у
різних шматочках за мною і кулі та слизу
рваних то сказ про ван їх концерті
Росії урд врятував ударна Європа в будинок
якщо їжа не машини
у дюссельдорфі андрей макаревич вийшов на
сцену футбол снопи сам love and peace in
West and East
топ то будь-якому там р-на заході закінчується
а розпускався концерт із писань на
політичні теми на російських
телеканалах андрей макаревич втомимося
часом заявляєте додали ridge та шкіри та
сам на моє обожнення брат і вкрасти у
телевізійних баталіях російською від
посмішок шині
його дратуті роду sim2 рача
необ'єктивність не об'єкти вниз то душ
агресивно форуму подання інформації
всього гарчати прибувають 1 1 ц стало
нормою
а ch передаєте дивляться шанс а що за з
або фільмі на військову тематику так і
адже жартуєш чим нас буту і декою свин і
а така форма пропаганди ми надра та
страшний ну я живий zara дитячих частина iv і
знаю зараз і така
запив тури роки на живій музикою шину
валянки пішов і в любліні пісні і кі
публіка
знаючи практично на згадку булочку 2000
завдання пити пиво вул та музикантам для них
учасника групи то андрей макаревич
місту цим людям естетство якорі знаєте
ковен Петро і мій вигляд музикант вин artist
with художник з головна
ми прийшли його послухати інек політика
макаревич музикант у польшу чергу чому
з ін ша і це крижана до прожила жити
вівці та вкрай їх своїх піснях вінці я
адже дзеркало я так чекай було
поважаються прикро за таку літери в нього
є своя думка
і ми Петро і моєму юшку візьму та й кишан
увальни до і поважають що якщо виступу
макаревича в Україні для дітей
переселенці з донбасу співаків русі
мові вал і сам музикант віршів про воду
таке довге
шлунок утку вання за раз на вигляд бажаю
червона ставши таку собі кохану на вигадку
ю травень на небо не завадять а ламінація
телком пластова
після завершення turn та анімешну
легенда російського уроку виступати у
франції ізраїлі та знову
в Україні